- Easily one of my favorite
episodes of 'Daily Vee'
this lunch got into some real insights,
some different thinking, and some
really powerful stuff here in Toronto.
So I hope you enjoy today's Daily Vee
(Alternative Rock Music)
- Oxygen to me, it's how everything works.
You know, and if you do it great,
you're getting people to do
things for the right reasons.
You know and that's cool.
Branding and propaganda
can get very close right?
That's why I throw in
for the right reasons.
Because that's long term.
But to me its not being
at the mercy of anybody.
I think what I like about my life is
I'm not at the mercy of anybody.
And a lot of that has to do with branding.
And just my own, kind of like,
lack of expectation of others.
Which makes it all upside, which is good.
So I think to me that's
what's been so interesting
about the auto industry is,
technology has stepped
right in the middle of
you and the end consumer
in a meaningful way.
And they have the leverage.
The amount of referral business
that goes on in this world,
the amount of money, dealerships pay
for referrals in one shape or form,
is a bad macroeconomic structure.
- It's unbelievably expensive.
- Not only is it unbelievably expensive,
the referrers are being kind to you still.
They have all the leverage.
Apple one day decided, it was
30 percent vig on the app.
Right?
You guys know what goes
on in the Apple world?
Like when you transact there,
Apple's vig is 30 percent.
Do you know how crazy?
That's a big number.
You know if one player
in the referral business
decides to double the fee
because they can afford to,
they'll all be double
and you're going to do nothing about it.
You have no leverage.
Brand is the only thing
that can stop that.
Got it?
Brand is the one thing that
goes from utility, to emotional.
- So I have a quick question
about what goes along with branding.
So our dealer group, we have 12 stores.
Not all of them are named the
same, but our name is Pfaff
and we're trying to brand the name Pfaff
and get the name out there.
But we have a Porsche
dealership, a McLaren dealership,
some luxury high end dealerships,
what is more important to focus on?
The Porsche name, the McLaren name,
or to keep branding as Pfaff.
- Pfaff
- And get the name out there.
- It's not even close.
It's even a close debate.
- So that's what we've
on the path of doing.
- It's so much, it's so important,
that if that was my family business
and I looked at the contracts,
and there was a way for us to
fire somebody not doing it,
and they were the biggest economic driver,
I would spend all my life
convincing my dad we had to fire them.
That's how much of a non debate it is.
- So should we switch all of the
new acquisitions that we've
got to the name Pfaff, as well?
- You should do whatever
you think is right Gene.
But if I was part of the business,
and I had say,
It'd be the only thing I care about.
It's the answer that I just
gave the gentleman there.
It's the only, brother,
it's the only thing you got.
It's the only thing you have.
It doesn't feel like that, right?
That doesn't win the sprint,
Porsche wins the sprint.
Pfaff wins the marathon.
- We were having the same conversation.
I actually, I'll admit
I said the opposite.
- I get it.
- Right?
It's because the end consumer
isn't the person buying so.
- You're right about that but
you're just not playing
out the chess of it all.
- Can you walk me through it?
- Sure.
In four years when
Porsche sends you an email
and says you've got 18
months and we're out.
You're going to be like fuck.
(Laughing)
- You can still sell the oranges or
the lawn mowers, or
the pre-owned anything.
- But Jimmy, on that note
guys, I'm gonna say it.
I want to make sure you understand it.
Nintendo was a playing card company.
Nintendo started as a playing card company
I started off as a wine merchant.
Like, I get it.
But I actually usually
think the number one move
when shit is interesting,
is to leverage while you've got it
the building of the other
thing with the assumption
that the first thing might
not even be there at all,
and then taking it all as upside.
And then you can get smart right?
The orange is kind of silly,
lawn mowers a little bit closer.
But what about, why can't you guys start
the coolest air refreshment
thing in a car company
out of your little one stop?
Like why couldn't somebody here create
the ten dollar premium
air refresher, why not?
You could.
And you'd have pretty much as
much permission to do it as anybody else.
I'll go a different place with you.
I think that BMW and Porsche and Mercedes
should be going into other sectors.
I'll go the reverse.
I think if I'm at Mercedes and I'm the CEO
I would be creating an Alexa,
Google Home, Apple Homepod
competitor because I have
permission because of my brand,
to be behind engineering
and high quality product.
Why should Braun be the
biggest razor in the world?
I would buy BMW's razor.
So, you know, you gotta think about
where you have permission to hedge.
- Some of these guys are
already doing stuff like that,
like making bicycles and making this.
- Makes sense, that's cool.
- You can buy anything that's
branded Harley Davidson.
- Because Harley Davidson
really built a brand.
Whoever was running, like I know nothing.
But like whoever was running that ship,
in probably that era.
They went all the way.
I actually think they went too far.
I think of Harley Davidson
similar to Playboy.
I think sometimes you
whore out your name so much
that you dilute it so
you have to be careful.
- 60 percent of our sales
are in motor clothes,
rather than actual physical motorcycles.
- Which by the way may be great.
You know it's funny
sometimes you look at margin,
you know my dad's business,
I'm trying to convert Wine Library,
It's called Wine Library.
I'm trying to get my dad to
basically become a food store.
You know I'm not a scholar.
I didn't go to Yale, and
did a couple studies,
and am a good public
speaker and wrote a book,
and we're having this conversation.
I do what you do.
There's never been a day,
The day I left college
at 22 I drove from Boston
to New York, to New Jersey, to home.
I got there at 4:18 and
worked from 4:18 to 7:30
before me and my dad went home.
This is the day I left college.
From that moment on to the
second I'm sitting here
right now, I have never
not operated as a CEO,
of business in my life.
Even in transition between Wine Library
and the building of Gary Vee,
I was the CEO of Vayner Media.
Yes I was a little more
passive than AJ was.
But it wouldn't be there without me.
I don't say this stuff in theory.
This is not theory for me.
This is not intellectual.
This is practical reality.
I think the way I communicate
it feels hyperbolized,
because I'm a showmen.
But now I'm in an interesting
part in my career,
because now I have some history behind me
that makes it a little,
it's a little harder
to completely laugh me
off the state, you know?
Because you keep winning
that much, it's hard.
That's why I built Vayner Media.
Madison Avenue, tough
place, big companies,
holding companies,
billion dollar companies,
he's just a Twitter kid.
The articles are on the internet.
Twitter boy thinks he
can win Madison Avenue.
This fuckin' kid, they didn't say that.
This guy thinks, that's
what they wanted to say.
This guy thinks he's a big shot.
It's a lot harder to build
a Madison Avenue agency
is than to get some Twitter followers.
Vayner Media is the fastest
growing organic top line
revenue agency in the
history of the business.
Seven years, 150 million dollars, no M&A,
all organic, no cash infusion.
That doesn't happen
because I'm charismatic.
That happens because I operate.
- So how do you handle work life balance?
- Communication.
- Good Answer.
- I always think what my
wife would've said to that.
- Day trading communication.
If my wife texts me right now
and she's like "fuck this"
I won't go to Chicago right now,
I'll fly home, and I'll
talk til it's not fuck this.
Now a lot of it was back
to making good strategies.
Like I at a young age knew
who I needed to marry.
I didn't know it.
You know us guys, and
we're mainly guys here.
When you're younger you're like
you want your girl to
be obsessed with you.
I didn't realize how desperately I needed
to marry somebody who
was super independent.
And had her own shit, you know?
That's funny to me in
hindsight of the teenage me
would've never thought that right?
So my wife's super her own person,
and she's a stay at home mom.
But from a framework she doesn't
need me you know kind of.
Which is interesting.
And then in extremism.
So Monday through Friday
when I'm on the field,
it's seven am to Midnight.
And then on the weekends I'm
completely checked out at home,
and I take seven full weeks of vacation,
completely checked out.
And that's it, extremism.
Something that won't work for most.
You know, you don't know what's going on
in somebodies bedroom right?
I'll give you another answer.
Maybe even more important
that communication.
I'm just not interested
in your guys opinion
on my parenting style.
Too many people are pandering
to the current state of political
correctness of parenting.
- Everyone has their own way.
- That's right, and I'm
apathetic to it I get it.
But I actually, I actually
am on the record of this,
I do believe this co-parenting concept
will be looked upon in 100
years from now as wrong.
I do not believe in
two cooks in a kitchen.
There's no such thing as co CEO's.
- So you leave everything
for her to decide?
- Or him, I think in 70 years,
I think we all know couples where
when you look at their DNA,
the women or the man should be at work,
the women or the man should be at home.
So I think we went through
women at home, man.
Now we're living through another,
starting to get into a co-parenting thing.
And we'll do this for another 20-30 years.
I think our kids, and probably
more likely our grandkids,
are gonna be really smart
and audit with each other
and be like.
You have a higher capacity to earn,
I have a higher capacity to nurture.
And then let's go because
boy I know ten couples
where the woman's at home
and she's 50 fucking times
more capable than the guy.
And I know equally as many couples
where she's a disaster
and not nurturing at all
and he's the most lovely
thing of all time.
I think that's going to be
the future of parenting.
I think so.
I think it's practical.
Bon Apetit
- What's your biggest miss?
- My biggest miss is definitely the things
that I haven't done.
So I don't know them in detail.
Because that's my biggest issue.
Cripple by opportunity, right?
The biggest misses black and white are,
I was super right about YouTube,
a company called Viddler
came along, and gave me seven
percent of their company
to move my Wine Library show to Viddler.
And I stopped producing
for YouTube up until
a year and a half ago.
And I left ungodly amounts of branding
on the table over the last decade.
I passed on Uber's angel round twice.
If you guys go take outta
the library Crush It,
my first book.
I had only acknowledged one
person in my acknowledgements
besides my parents, my family.
And that's Travis the CEO of Uber.
Because he's a dear friend of mine and
I passed on a friend
of mines company twice
and it ended up being Uber.
So that's pretty black and white.
I didn't answer the email
that reads like this.
Hey Garry Vee we're huge fans we
desperately want you to
invest in our company
we'd love to have a meeting.
Didn't even reply to the email.
That came from AirBnB.
I was so right that I
have such real losses.
You know because you
couldn't get them all, right?
I don't have the losses
that most people have,
Because I have never done anything
financially that could hurt me really bad.
I'm stunned by people's
ability to do things
that can put you out of business.
Like overextending yourself.
I don't do that.
Now I'm not, if I don't have
the cash I don't do that.
I'm willing to borrow.
I mean I got a lease at Hudson Yards
that scares the shit outta me.
Right?
But those are a little more calculated.
One of the biggest reasons
I built my personal brand,
is I used Gary Vee as an
insurance policy for my life.
Like if all else fails, I can
make 20 million dollars a year
speaking and writing books.
That's the most ridiculous thing
I've ever said in my life, but it's true.
And it's awesome.
So I think I did that, but
I also did it for branding.
Vayner Media doesn't pick RFP's.
Last week. Five of the
biggest 500 businesses
in the world and said will
you take our business.
That's called brand you know?
So, we don't have a sales team.
We don't have a head of new business.
And we're the fastest growing,
let the market come to you.
The person that asks,
gives up the leverage.
Sales.
That's why it's hard.
They way I knew the internet
was going to be big,
the way I knew e-commerce, the way email,
and Google AdWords, I was
building, by not being educated,
by not knowing rich people,
I came from like a very funny place.
I didn't know a lot of stuff.
I didn't even know
venture capital existed.
So I'm like wait a minute.
This is interesting
I'm good at things,
like this is not a joke.
I'm like I understand,
I'm not a good salesman.
I'm not a good wine
merchant, I'm good at things.
So I started reading
everything about YouTube
selling for two billion dollars.
And I don't know if you guys remember
when YouTube sold for two billion.
It was one point seven.
It was in 2007 or 2008,
I don't remember exactly.
But if you remember, that was like a
trillion dollars at the time.
Remember?
Good, I'm glad you guys remember
That was like, a trillion.
A trillion's a lot.
If I woke up this morning and
Snapchat sold for a trillion.
I'd be like whoa that's a lot.
So it hit me that hard and it
was something that I understood
as one of the first 50,000
people to understand.
So I'm like there's something in that.
In that digging I read
about angel investors.
Then I Googled angel investor.
This is why I always give this advice.
And I'm like oh you can
invest in companies?
I'm being serious with you.
There's certain things I'm good at,
there's certain things I'm not.
Before they go on the stock market?
Then I started really getting into tech.
And I was like this is
going to eat the world.
That's when I basically,
binarily over night,
decided everything that's happening
now will basically eat up everything.
Everything.
And so I started really learning,
I started reading tech crunch every day.
And then I went to
South By Southwest 2007.
And at that South By Southwest
2008 Twitter was exploding.
And everyone was shitting
on it, even the tech kids.
They're like who cares if you..
Because it was psychology
it wasn't utility.
Everybody was like who
cares, you know you'd have
real tech people, the people
that now you all know.
Like very famous and
then some that you don't.
But they'd sit here and
I'd be at the BBQ pit,
because I'm listening right?
For all my talking, and I'm
doing a lot of it today,
I listen all the time.
And I'm listening, and they're like
who gives a shit if you
walk the dog this is stupid.
Nobody's gonna care that
you're eating pizza.
And I'm sitting there and I'm
like everybody's gonna care.
I'm like that's what we do.
That's what life is.
We don't want to admit it.
So that's what I'm good at.
Right?
I knew that everybody was
gonna put their credit card
into a computer when everybody
told me they wouldn't.
Every one of you is gonna
retna scan everything.
Because it's going to save you time.
I knew that everybody
was gonna online date
when everybody thought it was
the weirdest shit ever in 2000.
It's just time arbitrage.
It will be the thing
we trade on every time.
I get an email from Dave
Moren the head of Platform,
it says, Mark would love for you to come
and speak to the company
about why you believe this.
I said, I'll be there tomorrow.
I flew out to Palo Alto.
I spoke in front of the company
when it was the size of
this conference I just gave.
I only spoke about consumer behavior.
Because at that point there
was something weird about
Facebook that they really were doing
what I would do if I knew how to do that.
So I went weird.
It was I had ever spoken.
I didn't even know how to articulate it.
Right?
I didn't know Mark was there.
He sat all the way in the back, slouched.
Came down, goes do you want
to have dinner tonight?
I said, I sure do.
We had dinner.
He was one of the only people
I've ever met in my life
that I've thought had the
same intuitive understanding
about people as I do.
Which is super funny to me
because the way he's portrayed
in the movie is super, like
he's so not introverted.
He's introverted in some ways.
But in a macro he's all time.
We became friendly, he would
come to New York a bunch
and I would see him.
Which are going to be
great stories one day
to tell my grandkids.
And one day his sister called me, Randy
And said, "Our parents,
Mark and I's parents
want to sell a bunch
of stock to buy a house
and we'd really like you
to be part of the family.
Would you like to buy some stock?"
And I said, "I sure do."
I was in the back of taxi in Miami.
I will never forget that
moment my whole life.
I put in every dollar I
had in my bank account
except for 100,000 dollars,
and I have not sold one share since.
Thank you, thanks for having me.
It was really nice meeting you guys.
Have a good day take care. Bye.
What was your favorite insight,
your favorite new insight,
from today's episode?